why is the universe so damn quiet out
there
why is the universe in three dimensions
rather than ten
could we code a supercomputer into a
proton
the three body problem and its two
sequels the dark forest and death's end
try to answer progressively more bizarre
scientific questions
and i want to be clear i don't finish
series trilogies of books very often
but in doing so this became one of my
favorite science fiction series that i
have ever read session lou the author
for the three body problem won the hugo
award for best novel for this book
and let's look at why that was deserved
what do you think momo
do you think the three body problem
deserved it no no no you think
you think you want chin scratches there
we go
there we go oh
but first what's it about well the free
body problem is about
um it's about this group of people that
they
uh um okay
most importantly it's about ideas ideas
in the way that old science fiction
of navin and arthur c clarke and asimov
were a lot of the time it's about
complex ideas and the discussion about
them plot wise
it's kind of hard to describe without
giving everything away but
it's about humanity's first contact with
an alien civilization
except that they're not here yet
except that they kind of are and they
won't be here for hundreds of years
capiche okay it's a book about slowly
figuring out who these aliens are
why they're coming from all the way out
there and what we
should do or not do about it should we
talk with them
should we fight them if we were to fight
them how would we fight them who should
even be in charge in the first place or
should we just let them come
maybe it'll be great now you may love
this book for the same reason that a lot
of people
really hated it and if you look at
goodreads or amazon reviews then they
will mention
this it is packed full of dense
complicated
often bizarre scientific concepts and
seashell will just take
two pages to explain it to you it's
expositiony in many ways you might look
at it like that
but i found it compelling because it's
really cool ideas that he's talking
about and
the way that it works into the book is
quite brilliant at many times i mean not
just quite brilliant like it's
genuinely incredibly brilliant i just
used way too many adjectives
this book and the two sequels even more
so just went way further than most of
the hard science fiction that i'm used
to reading
and the way that xianlu did it was
really cool because
he sort of introduces a lot of concepts
that are very real that we
know work that aren't just theory like
super hard graphite materials or
space elevators which could conceivably
happen
even within our own lifetimes but then
he also introduces some really bizarre
speculative stuff you know like building
a
supercomputer into a proton
but he does it in a way that really
blurs the line between stuff that we
know is possible and is pretty
speculative that might not be that we're
not sure about it's kind of just there
in theory
and the way that he meshes them together
he convinces you that it's all possible
that this
is how things could work so it gives you
the simpler stuff and you
buy into the more bizarre stuff but at
the same time i want to be clear that
this is not a
character-driven novel and the
characters in the book
can feel pretty wooden at times this is
partly because they're often used as
representations for ideas more than
they're meant to be kind of their own
independent characters
and the fact that it was originally
written in chinese means that as it was
translated over
a lot of the dialogue the way people
talk doesn't
feel like the way people should talk to
english speakers
that's not a fault of the book but it
does affect how you might experience it
and engage with the characters
i didn't really feel like i needed that
deep character-driven stuff but if you
were the sort of person where you don't
like dense scientific concepts or you
really depend on those characters to get
immersed in a story
then this may not be the book for you
and that's okay it can be quite
abrupt if it's not what you're used to
like there's this moment in death's end
where he just says
and then she lost the ability to speak
for a few days and then she got it back
basically but stylistically i don't
think any of that really undermined any
of the real
draw for me to this story this
fascinating exploration of our place in
the universe
the actual way that it's written can
feel quite strange to an english speaker
as it was written in chinese there's
a lot of puns and there's a lot of
references that chinese readers would
understand but we don't they do actually
however give us some in the footnotes
which i always found
really interesting that like hey this
name means this or this is a reference
to this event from the chinese cultural
revolution
part of this is because of the chinese
cultural context of the book most of it
is told from the perspective of
chinese characters in chinese history
with a lot of references to
chinese culture and the history that
surrounds it
so some of that nuance is going to be
lost on
you as english speakers the writing
style can also feel
unfamiliar at points i mentioned how the
dialogue can feel wooden but also
transitions for example they might just
say and then one year passed which
feels strange and very abrupt for us
reading it but that's not on the book
that's not a stylistic problem with the
book that is all to do
with my experience as an english speaker
and
reader and i actually think that reading
this sort of stuff it's good to expand
what we can be familiar with um so
for me it was actually kind of
enlightening to read a book with
such a different way of telling stories
and building worlds and characters uh
even if they're not the way that i'm
used to
and meant that i didn't quite get into
the characters as much as someone else
might if i spoke the language
but the story and the series more
broadly does have a collectivist
bent to it and what i mean by that is
that in
in the sequel the dark forest i remember
this distinct moment where he writes
and then earth solved all of their
problems and decided to work together
and i was just like what
just just baffled uh but apparently
that sort of collectivist utopian ideal
is more common in uh in chinese fiction
whereas i'm a lot more used to
individualist fiction where there's
there's a lot more focus on individual
characters
the the movers of these stories of the
three-body problem the dark forest and
death scene
are organizations they're groups of
people much more than the individual
characters
western media does also have stories
that put more of an emphasis on the
community and the collective rather than
the individual
a star trek does this quite a bit but
apparently it is more common
in chinese fiction than we might have it
now i do want to give you a warning
because the three-body problem the first
book in the series
did feel weirdly
young adultish when i was first reading
it for the first kind of
part of it you know you've got all of
the world's smartest people
being invited to uh join a secret
society and solve this complicated
science problem that no one else can
called the three body problem and i
won't tell you how it fits into the
story because it's
a brilliant reveal but uh
it felt kind of younger in in how it was
uh
playing out but as it progresses it
definitely does become more complicated
and
more mature and that feeling definitely
went away for me
the book is divided up into a couple of
perspectives one
in the wake of the chinese cultural
revolution at a secret chinese military
base
and one in the present trying to figure
out the
consequences of what happened at that
base
now normally i'm always worried about
stories that split it up like this when
one is
clearly more fascinating than the other
but
seashell doesn't really suffer from this
at all there are so many
questions and answers in both of these
stories
and how they fit together because they
feel just
wildly disconnected for so long
uh and then how they come together it's
brilliant it genuinely is
amazing uh and it's such a unique way to
do it
that was one thing that really stuck out
to me is that you know the setting of
the chinese cultural revolution it's so
unlike anything that i'm used to in
science fiction and
seeing how that plays into quite
naturally
the events of the actual story and how
it leads up to it it's a mic drop moment
one thing to mention is that though the
three body problem does stand on its own
it's also pretty clearly written as a
set up book for the story that seashell
new
really wanted to tell in the dark forest
and death's end
and that's fine but it did mean that the
story ended in a place where i felt like
oh
so the story hasn't even started yet and
because of that
it is probably the weakest of the three
in the trilogy
and it's why the immediate sequel the
dark forest is easily the strongest of
the trilogy it's where the meat of that
story that i wanted to know about could
be found
and i don't actually have the dark
forest here because i lent it to a
friend after we read this
in less than a week
it's that good it's also the most
character-driven of the three he spends
a lot of time getting us
invested in the perspective character
and it has a strong
thematic central scientific question
that drives the plot
why is it so quiet out there
and it all builds together to a really
profound
ending but if you like speculative but
also hard science fiction
then get the three body problem and its
sequel
the dark forest that's all from me let
me know what you would like me to review
next
down in the comments below i have been
reading a lot
and if i haven't read it tell me what
you'd like me to read
down in the description below anyways i
gotta go
stay nerdy and i'll see you in the
future
you